Target has breached
Goura Absolute Defense Line.
Here it is.
We're ready for you this time.
Raise your A.T. Fields
as soon as the music starts.
Follow the plan from there.
Got that, you two?
-Roger!
Target has entered the mountains.
Listen up! We're going balls to the wall,
full speed ahead from the get-go!
I know. We'll finish this in 62 seconds.
-Target is about to reach Point Zero!
-Jettison external power plugs!
Launch!
TIME REMAINING
Both Evas accounted for!
-Oh, geez...
-How appalling.
Hey, what do you think
you're doing to my Unit 02?!
What?! You're the one
who came barreling into me!
You're the one who lost
the beat at the end!
You have your head
up your ass all the time!
And what were you doing
last night instead of sleeping?
I was doing visualization training
for today's battle!
You're full of it! I know you tried
to kiss me while I was sleeping!
No way! You were awake?!
That's horrible!
I said that as a joke,
but you really did? You kissed me?!
No, I didn't! I stopped myself!
Pervert! Weirdo! Freak!
I can't believe you!
You're the one who sleepwalked over
and started talking in your sleep!
They're making us look like fools again...